友）オープニングは？
オープニングはない
まってまってまってちょっと待って。
待って、骨とかおれたらマジ
そしたらお互い骨おれっからな
はじめしゃちょーのしょうもない実験コーナー
こんにちは、Dr.はじめだ。今日用意するのは・・・
こちらっ！
あぃ！あぃ！あぁぃっ！
まず用意するのはこちら、つかめる水です。
一時期、結構なんか話題になったと思うんですけども
水がつかめるというものでございます。
実際にもう、手でこうやって水自体をつかめるという、どうやって水がつかめてるのかといいますと、
わかりません
続いてはこちらウルトラエバードライ
これもねぇなんかけっこう使われてたんですけども、
何かと言いますと・・・
水を、完全にはじくようになるらしいでございます。
え、すごいなぁー
完全に水をはじくスプレーこれは。
これがかかると、基本的にもうまったく水が入らなくなるらしいです。
つかめる水をそのまま多分水とかにこう落としても
そのまま沈んでいくんですよ。水だから。
なんですけども、もし、このつかめる水に
ウルトラエバードライを全部かけて
（↑のとうりだお）
友）あり！！
すごくない！？
だってさ、普通に考えて水にょ（を）はじく水だよ？
ひょっとしたら水の上で水が踊るかもしれないってゆう
まざることであろう２つの物質がまざらない時
はたしてどのようなことがおきるのかという実験でございます。今回は。
今回要するにやりたいことちょっと複雑なんですけども
（上記の通りなのだ。）
やることがっ
高度になってきたゾっ（きらぁん）
ポピャピャピョン
つかめる水をひとまず作っていきまっしょう！
まずアルギン酸水を作ろうって。。。えっ！？
まずペットボトル。。。
まっ、まぁまぁ。
まぁまぁまぁまぁ。
（グチャビチャグヒャビョヒャ）
（ビャヒャビョヒャビャヒャヴォヒャ）
はい、白くなったのでこれで
20分程放置すると透明になるらしいです。
はぁぇ。。。（息の音）
え、どれくらい入れればいいの
きもっ、気持ちでいい。。。？？？
友）でっ、でかっ、でかめで作りたかったらでかめでもいい。
でかく作りたいんだよなぁ。
友）えっ、すごい。これもういきすぎじゃないいですか？
友2）えっ、でかっ、でかく作りましょうよ。
もっといく？
こぼれるくらい入れたるわ。もう。
こぉれぇわぁ！！！！！
待って。怖い怖い。。。ゆっくり入れるね。。。
友）えっ
友2）え、待ってぇ
友）浮いてきてるよ。
友2）浮いてきてる浮いてきてる。浮ういてきてるよぉ！
え、待って。なになになになに。
えぇすごいいい。。。どぉすればいい、どぉすればいい。。。
んんん〜〜〜〜〜はずれてぇえ〜〜〜
うぉ〜しよぉしよしよしよし
いいんじゃねこれ！
ほらもう、完全にほら！
もうクラゲクラゲ。
あぁ、カルシウム水に長くつけておくと硬くなっていくらしい。
友）あぁ、なるほどね。
もういいんじゃないでもほら。
やばいやばい。きてるきてるきてる。
はいきた完成ぃ〜〜〜。
こんなかんじで、ひとまずつかめる水は完成しました。
はい、とゆうわけでつかめる水が準備できたので
今からこのつかめる水に
ウルトラエバードライで完全防水をしていきます。
そうすることによってこのつかめる水は完全防水された水になってしまいますので
完全防水になった水を水の上にのせるとはたしてどうなるのか
ためしてみようと思います。
よいしょと
ウルトラエバードライかけていきます。
（ピシュウウウウアアアア）
（ピシュウウ）
これでこれが乾燥した後にこっちをかけます。
よぉし。
はい、というわけで
えぇ、無事コーティングができたんですけども
えぇ、これもう
わぁ、割れたのかなぁ
なんかぁ。。。うぁ、やばいやばい。
もう、われっ、中身がない！！！
けどひとまずこれはコーティングされてるんで
これ浮けば成功ですから。
早くお風呂場にぃ！！！！！！早く！！！！！！！
はっはやくはやくはやく！！！！！！！！！
じゃあまずコーティングしてないバージョンから。
ではコーティングしてないバージョンを入れるとっ
まぁ同じ水なんで沈んでいっちゃいますね。
沈んじゃいますね。
水に沈んじゃいます。
次はっ！！！！
防水でコーティングしてるやつですから
これで、浮けば！
浮けばっていうかなんかはじいてれば！
今回の実験は成功という訳です。
じゃあいきます！
（ピッチャ）
じゃあいきます。
はいっ！！！！
（ぶわっしゃぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ）
つっちゃつちゃつちゃつちゃ
は〜はじめよお〜
いろいろお〜あるけどお〜
がんばれえ〜いいつも
おおえん〜してるう〜
もっもっやっしっ
友）www
友)wwwwww
友）ペンギンやwもうww